for now there's not much more to do than
stand around and talk about what
happened about what happens next this is
a place of shelter for more than a
thousand after the horror of Hurricane
Dorian police an army who are helping
out the relief effort see the government
has banned cameras inside or press
called me conditions are good it's the
stories that upset her I held I was
speaking to a lady last night from in
iveco and she was crying she said how
many of our family members she saw
washed away in the flooding in the mud
and she's saying that she's she don't
understand why we know that god is angry
but the extent of the damage and the
lives loss is so hard when the storm hit
Freetown her daughter had to swim to
safety we had this word from the long
way other all the way up to the hill no
this is our Doppler weather radar and
now another storm is bearing down on the
place she's not sure if she still calls
home there was really nowhere else to
stay if you really look at it because
the places are waterlogged and if
they're not waterlogged there's no power
there's no water the dark clouds are
ominously hanging over the Bahamas the
prime minister says they are hoping the
potential tropical storm will cause few
problems but people are ready but if you
were to fly over those islands that were
impacted you would note that many of the
homes already have taps on the roofs etc
trying to minimize any form of leakage
within the home itself so people have
been working already
late on Friday the UN secretary-general
turd one of the places where this place
people are being housed any worries this
site is going to become more common ibly
so this is the moment to reverse the
present trend climate change is running
faster than what we are we need to
reverse this trend we need to defeat
climate change the number of those
missing still stands at 1300 but new
telecommunications equipment has been
sent to the islands that were worst
affected the hope is the better
information will bring that number down
there's a storm just
off the Bahamas the people here are
hoping the missus because its current
path puts it towards islands that
already had too much to beer
Island Fisher al-jazeera in Nassau in
the Bahamas